millions of people gain strengths and
find solace take comfort in the sense of
community that faith and religious
ceremony can provide
it's what so many rely on especially in
times of crisis
now with churches mosques and temples
close the way we come together to pray
to grieve to celebrate new life has had
to change faith is a long game and as
Redman Shannon explains religions all
over the world are learning new lessons
on how to cope social distancing at the
western wall face guards in the Far East
and honking for Jesus in the u.s. south
the covert 19 pandemic has changed how
we worship gathering together is a
fundamental part of prayer millions
possibly billions of worshippers have
had to modify or totally suspend
congregating some have resisted orders
trusting God before government but most
have bowed down for the greater good
[Music]
mechas Grand Mosque has been almost
deserted for Ramadan this year everybody
across the world where we're normally
used to it being a very community
spirited month we're having to adapt to
stay at home rukmi Ahmed works with a UK
charity that normally arranges huge
gatherings welcoming Muslims and
non-muslims to celebrate her two giant
iftar events breaking the daily fast but
this year it's all moved online and so
where we would have our normal open
iftar events we've essentially just
taken that virtually and this is
operated on zoom and broadcast on our
face but livestream channels as well one
thing that we've actually found is that
we
reached out from two more communities
than ever before so we've had people
from Australia join our Iftars Iman
aspects on America a different faith on
a different continent for the same sense
of generosity volunteers at this Sikh
temple in Surrey BC are delivering
thousands of meals to those who are
isolated and to frontline workers the
gurdwaras doors have been open to only
50 people a day a restriction that
affects more than just prayer it's also
actually a social activities in in this
in the temples people older pupils comes
for the social activities and they meet
each other you know so is everything is
stopped so the elder people's they have
a very difficult time as mani worship
from home staff prepare for new measures
in the new normal praying by appointment
in shifts if people some more people
wants to come we will make that for
chefs to be can make the five shapes
technology has truly been a blessing for
believers of all faiths this pandemic
would have been very different just a
decade ago but Skype worship isn't quite
possible for everyone particularly for
Orthodox Jews on the Sabbath we don't
operate the you just don't use our
iPhones we don't operate electricity
everything is prepared in advance we
don't travel in the cards Rabbi David
Rosen says some people have gathered
online before Shabbat others just do the
best they can buy my parkin about
fifteen of us meeting they keeping
social distance say no to eateth and
wearing masks and being able to pray
together luckily enough in a part of the
world where the climate enables us to be
able to do that people often look to
places of worship during epidemics in
hope and in sorrow this church saw the
worst horrors of the Great Plague of
London in 1665 one that killed a fifth
of the city's population
Reverend cannon Allison Joyce has led a
special candle every
day since the church was forced to close
she is inspired by her predecessor
Richard Pearson from 355 years ago I
can't help wondering how what kept him
going what kept him going when it was
day after day after day of that kind of
unremitting tragedy he buries whole
families he buries his congregation
members he buries people whose names he
doesn't know they just found the body
and somehow he kept going
now Corbett 19 sermons are broadcast
online featuring mp3 readings from
worshipers at home do not let your
hearts be troubled the church has even
created a kid's newsletter to replace
Sunday school this week's had a whole
feature on my cat can enjoy says
difficult decisions lie ahead when the
church reopens particularly when it
comes to administering Holy Communion
there's been a lot of heartache but also
some remarkable gifts as well I think
we're learning to do ministry in a
completely different way and we're
learning lessons that like many churches
will take forward into the future as
well I mean it's been a time of great
opportunity precisely because we've had
to rethink everything that we do